thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video where you can create your own
website or online store the cost of
going to college may be at an all-time
high but so is its enormous value for
many students going to college is hardly
a choice putting them on a collision
course with a college board the company
that rules education if you've ever
taken the SAT P SAT or an AP class the
College Board has cashed your check and
they do it as a tax-exempt nonprofit
organization despite making millions and
profit every year we'd love to think the
college applications we work so hard on
are carefully reviewed in detail but
that's just not the case colleges can
get seventy eighty thousand applications
a year so it's just not practical to
spend more than a few minutes on each
one and that's if you're lucky
many schools automate the admissions
process with algorithms that sort
applications into bins before anyone
ever reads them and to do this they need
objective numeric values to input and
the SAT offers exactly that let's just
hope they're nothing like the You Tube
algorithms
another benefit of the SAT has to do
with grade inflation colleges need to
know that an a at one school has the
same value at another which is a much
bigger problem than you might think
here's a graph of grades over time and
it's not at all what you'd expect GPA is
rising incredibly quickly
the most common grade in high school and
college is now an a whether you think an
a should mean the top 20 percent of a
class or simply however many students
perform at that level this is a big
problem
there's no nationwide newsletter telling
teachers what last year's ninety percent
is worth today
every school inflates grades differently
and some not at all if you compare this
great inflation between schools you can
see just how much it varies between
institutions
so when letter grades mean less and less
the SAT means more than ever
the College Board tests need to be
exceptions more objective measures of
performance they aren't curved based on
how well everyone else does but they do
account for differences between tests to
make sure that a score in January of
this year is equivalent to that same
score in say
October of 2013 they adjust scores based
on how much easier or harder any
particular test is so these tests really
are useful but make no mistake they're
designed that way for profit if you've
ever taken an AP test the process is all
too familiar you pay the college board
an absurd amount of money for the
privilege of sitting in a cold room for
three hours and then anxiously await
your score after months of waiting and
all the hours you spent studying you're
gifted with a single digit no feedback
no justification one single digit and if
you actually want to send your score to
colleges which is the point of taking
the test you'll need to pay an
additional fee but who can blame them
it's probably very costly to send a one
digit number between computers as
frustrating as this is the College Board
is far from the only obnoxious company
used by schools there's MyMathLab
PowerSchool Chromebooks lanschool moodle
blackboard WebAssign WileyPLUS alex web
work and many many more
all these seem designed to irritate yet
they're in almost every school there's
only one way to make sense of this these
companies really have one customer not
actually students but schools the
College Board is so popular not because
they make a good reasonably priced
product but because they provide what
colleges want so students have no choice
schools buy what saves them time or
takes legal boxes so that's who these
companies design for everything else
like how they actually work for students
is pretty much irrelevant according to
their mission statement the College
Board is a mission driven not-for-profit
organization that connects students to
college success and opportunity the
problem is it acts a lot more like a
business with a monopoly than a generous
service for students the college board
president makes over seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year and their
average salary for executives is upwards
of $300,000 now there's nothing wrong
with trying to retain important
employees or even rewarding their
success but the College Board pretends
to exist for the benefit of students
while charging them unnecessarily high
prices they'll sell you a practice book
for the PSAT which is itself practice
for the SAT and then charge you a fee to
use
SCOR if their website goes down and it
often does when scores are released no
problem you can hear your score over the
phone for just a $15 extra even after
squeezing every penny they can from
students they turn around and sell our
personal information to recruiters and
colleges it's true that students can
take the AC T instead of the SAT and IB
instead of a P but that's a lot like
saying Comcast isn't a problem because
there are other internet providers even
when students do have the option of
taking the AC T or SAT at their school
both charged the same ridiculous prices
both companies would rather respect the
other's territory than compete and be
forced to lower profits the SAT rules
the toasts and the AC T in between
College Board's own ap microeconomics
curriculum explains quote it's important
to emphasize that monopolies can cause
market failures when they use their
market power to engage in behavior that
restrains competition but I'm afraid no
emphasis is necessary ap students learn
this concept all too well when they go
to pay for their tests thanks College
Board a lot of people ask me about
getting started on YouTube whatever your
idea on or off YouTube my advice is to
start with something you can do today if
the idea is interesting enough to
intrigue you it probably can't be done
in a day so you'll either put it off or
start and quickly get discouraged but if
you get a feeling of accomplishment
early on you're way more likely to
mentally invest in the project long term
this is where Squarespace can help you
can make a website with a nice custom
domain and even an online store in
minutes not hours or days it builds that
momentum to keep working on your project
Squarespace turns what would otherwise
be a whole other project into a single
easy step of your bigger goal I like how
easy it is to use but even more than
that how much control you have over the
design it never looks like you're just
editing a template but it is that easy
so to turn your idea into a real living
project go to Squarespace comm slash
poly matter that's pol Y ma tter you'll
get 10% off your first web site or
domain and help support this channel in
the process thanks again to Squarespace
but how did College Board get so big in
the first place watch the new video from
my friend
business-casual to find out
[Music]